all right let's get into audience
questions for the week first one david
what do you think the impact is of
donald trump's acquittal at his second
impeachment this is this is a good
question you know there were tons of hot
takes after trump was acquitted for the
second time last saturday
about now what what is the impact and
there were some articles saying trump is
acquitted but weakened and others saying
trump is revitalized i think that all of
those takes are basically bs in the
sense that the acquittal was a foregone
conclusion all along we knew that there
were not going to be 17 republican
senators willing to vote to convict
convict witnesses or no witnesses
evidence or no evidence you could have a
signed letter from trump saying i
deliberately incited the riot and
planned to do it all along and they
still would have acquitted donald trump
so i don't think the conviction or
acquittal itself
if it had been a conviction would be
different i don't think the acquittal
itself
really changes that much i think it's
too soon to say
what the
now post-second impeachment trumpian
movement is is uh going to do or the
direction it's going to go because we're
really in uncharted territory here trump
has said he wants to stay in politics
trump has talked about will be back
rumors about a 2024 run it might happen
it might not happen trump could just be
totally bored with politics by then
trump might just be exhausted he may
feel like he's too old for i mean just
who knows it's really really difficult
to know
but
the most interesting aspect of the
acquittal
for the immediate is how does it impact
republicans in 2021 gubernatorial races
and how does it impact republicans in
2022
the people who voted to acquit
and the people in the house who so some
of the senators who voted to acquit and
everybody in the house who voted not to
impeach
has an election in 2022 and that's still
a long time the american political
memory
is quite short in many ways um but it
will be a real question as to whether
there are repercussions to those
who were on what i would argue is
obviously the wrong side when it comes
to impeachment will republican voters
hold them accountable or not
most republican voters for now seem to
be very much behind trump so there may
there may be no accountability and you
could see in 2022 the most trumpian
brown-nosers people uh in the senate but
also the real sycophants who are only
here because of trump in the house like
marjorie taylor greene madison cawthorne
lauren beaubert and some others if they
get re-elected in 2022 which is still a
ways from now but the campaigns are
starting in the next seven eight months
unbelievably if they get re-elected it
is a real sign
that that faction has won out in the
republican party and then what happens
in terms of a possible split we talked
last friday i think it was
about 100 former republican officials
many from the bush era some from trump
others
who are saying we're leaving the
republican party and we're going to
start a traditional conservative party
if the trumpian wing is cemented as the
wing
sort of like when we talk about the
virus you've got the main variant and
then what else you've got these other
variants but then those other variants
can take over and become the dominant
variants if trumpian
politics becomes the dominant republican
strain
you may see
traditional republicans split off at the
same time the reverse could happen you
could see a rejection of these green
bobert hawthorne types and maybe they
will end up splitting off what seems
very clear to me is that at least as of
right now
if trump wants the nomination in 2024 it
is essentially his for the taking we
have new polling that tells us about
that and we're going to talk about that
in an upcoming segment
one other thing to think about as far as
trump goes is that historically voters
don't like losers
trump has lost and he has shed some
support among republican voters he still
has a lot of support but he has lost
some of it
the people that stay are more likely to
be the real die hard radicals and if you
see that willingness to follow trump
elsewhere which right now is at 64
percent of republicans if it drops to 50
if it drops to 40 if it drops to 30
by 2022
that is going to dramatically change
what's possible in terms of uh upcoming
elections for donald trump and that's
actually the next question so let's go
right into that
if you are anything like me you probably
aren't thrilled with the idea of going
into a doctor's office right now and
thankfully there's a practical and
affordable way
to take control of your health and get
personalized care from the comfort of
your home it's a service called steady
md they're one of our sponsors you take
a quiz you get matched with a licensed
primary care physician who understands
your health needs you have a one-hour
video call with your new doctor you
establish a meaningful relationship with
them and after that your doctor is
available to you anytime by text phone
or video chat this is not a random
doctor on call
each doctor at steady md has a limited
number of patients so they actually have
time to listen to you you get the
personal attention that you deserve they
can do almost everything an in-person
doctor can do perform medical
evaluations talk to you about health
concerns send prescriptions to your home
or local pharmacy and anything they
can't do online they'll quickly set you
up with an in-person provider to do
things like blood tests as an example
you don't need insurance it's only 99
bucks a month with no other fees or
co-pays there are so many practical
advantages to using steady md for
primary care
and it's also so much more affordable go
to
steadymd.com
pacman to take the free quiz see which
doctor is right for you i took their
quiz they matched me with a doctor who
specializes in my particular health
needs and situation the doctor they gave
me is a really perfect fit for me and my
medical needs there's no risk no
commitment to get started just click the
link right underneath this video